yo
yo yo it's your favorite youtube host
dave ruben this is the reuben report
direct message
for january 14th 2020
and on today's show i'm doing an ask me
anything q a
i've got a gajillion questions here that
were submitted on my
locals community that's
locals.reubenreport.com that is the only
place
that i take questions it is the only
place that i respond to people and i
respond
to dozens of people every single day uh
so you can join us over there i have not
even looked at these questions uh
michael my producer just handed them to
me i quickly flipped through
just to make sure the papers weren't
sticking to each other and uh and we're
just gonna jump in
and uh go until my brain decides to shut
off and then
that'll be it uh before i get into the
questions though obviously there's gonna
be some stuff about the election i have
no doubt about that and the censorship
and all that stuff
i just want to quickly talk about the uh
impeachment
vote yesterday because the house did
vote to impeach donald trump in eight
hours um i think it was a little
short-sighted
okay uh we're just finding out just in
the last 24 hours
this was sort of breaking as they were
voting on impeachment
and in effect there the reason for
impeachment impeachment
was that he incited the mob that went to
capitol hill okay so let's just put that
aside for a second as it was happening
the fbi was was releasing information
that they now have
that the riot uh and the assault on
capitol hill was pre-planned so it's
like well
which one of these is true did he incite
it or
did it happen meaning was a pre-plan did
it happen earlier did something happen
earlier that made it happen
we know that people were actually
starting the assault on the capitol
while trump was
was talking anyway that's a little
insider baseball because we're in this
odd post-truth
world where it sort of doesn't matter
right like do you think that any
democrat or or of the 10 republicans who
voted on this thing do you think they
would have cared if they had that
information well actually it was
pre-planned and some of it was starting
while trump was still speaking
it's like no because everything's about
just sort of the information war and how
you can gain political points
and everything else the next step now
will be a senate vote which could
technically disqualify him
from holding future federal offices
meaning he wouldn't be able to run for
president in 2024.
my my suspicion is that regardless trump
does not want to run in 2024. i know a
lot of people don't
want to hear me say that but my sense is
that there there is a movement here
um that is going to be bigger than trump
right like you can kill a man but you
can't kill an idea i think it's
something like that with trump and the
ideas
of being proud of america and fighting
for freedom and allowing the states to
be free
and being pro-capitalism and proud of
our history and all those things
that will all continue i don't know that
he's going to do it i do think it's very
possible the junior
will will get involved in national
politics i think it's very possible that
ivanka will
there's a rumor now going around that
maybe she would run for senate in
florida so i think some of the people
associated with it
will continue i don't know that trump
specifically will but i do want to say
one other thing to
about this and then i'll jump into the
questions you know there was a moment
right
after the riots at the capitol there was
like a 24-hour
48-hour window where i think even
many of the art and trump supporters
were like you know what
this is out of control it doesn't matter
if he said they should be peaceful and
then people went or if he was winking to
them or whatever
your take on it is that's sort of
irrelevant i think there was a window
where a lot of people were like you know
what we don't like these images
it's time it's time like let's just move
forward there's nothing else the senate
can do we're not even going to hear
anything about the election like
let's just move past everything and
biden will be president and we'll figure
out how to move forward and everything
else
that happened for about 48 hours and
then they went so
crazy on banning trump from twitter and
facebook and spotify and instagram and
everything else and
and then now with the impeachment that i
think they've strengthened
the idea again right they've
strengthened the movement again and this
is just so consistent
with what the left has done about
everything in the last couple years it's
like they're driving this car
to crazy town right and they have all
these off-ramps where they could just
possibly moderate a little bit do
something a little bit decent just let
the guy leave
at this point right it's not that there
was going to be a whole bunch of crazy
rallies again and attacks and everything
else
everyone knows it you could feel it it
was deflating and they just
plow through all of the roadblocks the
roblox like don't go crazy anymore
crazytown is that way
and they just plow through so there were
there were venues
there were avenues i should say that
would have allowed people to get off and
just we could have done something that
would have actually been a little bit
like healing
but clearly we ain't going in that
direction all right one more thing
before i get
to the questions i want to talk to you
guys about
built bar i've got the coconut almond
in my hand right now people do love the
coconut uh you know guys it's a new year
if you're looking for a new protein bar
i've got just the brand for you built
bar
is the secret to keeping both of your
new new year's resolutions
eating healthier food and eating tastier
food built bars are low calorie low
sugar high protein high fiber
great for the keto diet i can actually
lose or maintain weight while indulging
in a yummy treat
healthy has never been this delicious
built bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors my personal favorite
as you know is the cookies and cream
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
including both
nut and nut-free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew
after the holidays we still want to
indulge but we also want to
shed those additional pounds i know how
that feels which is why build bars are
the perfect alternative to pie for the
health conscious
guy and coconut it's got 18 grams of
protein only 5 grams of sugar 5 net
carbs don't give up on your resolution
bill bar is the answer go to
billboard.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20 off
your next order use
promo code ruben for 20 off at
builtbar.com
and now back to me hello all right here
we go q a i'm going to plow through as
many as possible i'll try to give
somewhat brief answers so i can get to
everything i've got here it's going to
be a lot there's a lot of paper uh carol
asks are you seeing or hearing any
indications about how far the dems are
planning to go for example blow up the
filibuster add states pack the supreme
court etc
i hear biden talking about unity but i'm
not hearing that anywhere else look
i'll just say this again and again and
again and again i don't really think
biden's in charge of the operation biden
is just kind of the figurehead
and and where the energy is is for
all of those things getting rid of the
electoral college packing the courts
uh just disseminating awful information
to all of
our our schools to just continue to
brainwash people and free this and free
that
and all of the stuff that we know isn't
economically sane and it's not
it's not legally same you know if you're
going to pick
which types of people should get covered
relief which is something that biden
said the other day if you're black or
hispanic or
pacific islander you should get extra
covert relief or
asian he threw in there even though
asian people do incredibly well
socioeconomically in america but he
wants
the asian community votes so he wants
them to feel like a victim i think
there's just like the litany of stup
stupid bad ideas is just being smuggled
in right now
i think perhaps some version of the most
extreme of them will be
slightly guarded by a biden
administration as opposed to
if it had been a bernie administration
might have been just like all hell
breaking loose with all that stuff but
i'm not even sure what i mean by that
like i don't know what would be too
radical where
you know joe biden would be like no
that's too much i mean joe biden
literally was saying that
that men who identify as women should be
in women's prisons i mean that's
so it's like oh yeah he he's the
moderate he's the moderate guys and and
again this is what i was telling
all of my good liberal friends guys
you're just ushering
in all of the stuff that's going to
destroy everything you care about it's
going to destroy science and stem
and all the corporate board rooms you
care about and we're going to hire
people based on the color of their skin
and not the content of their character
oh and it's that guy uh martin luther
king
it's his birthday coming up right on
monday and uh
you know he wouldn't have been happy
about all this but he's old school you
know forget about him
uh ali says did you make any new year's
resolutions that you're willing to share
do you think that making resolutions at
one point in time every
year or two or three or more points is
good practice why am i not
i actually do try to make a new year's
resolution every year
a couple of years it's just generally
about like eating better or taking you
know better care of myself or that kind
of thing
i i will tell you my resolution this
year my my resolution this year
was to not be afraid and that maybe that
sounds a little corny or something
but i know in the last year you know as
i was completely open about my politics
right like
in these last five or six years i've
been very open about my political
evolution but i think i really became
much more bold and i don't hold back in
any way
in this past year and partly and this is
sort of what sucks about the publishing
world
i was holding back a little bit on some
of my feelings about trump and some of
the other things because i had written
don't burn this book a year before it
came out
in in april so when don't burn this book
came out in april in the midst of the
quarantine
and the lockdown and everything and i
was supposed to be on tour and we were
we had sold out a bunch of theaters and
it was it was going to be awesome and i
love and i
deeply miss going out on tour and we're
trying to figure out ways to do it maybe
in florida and texas
um think about it the book had been
written for about a year so i had been
sitting on all those ideas for a year
so the idea is when i started doing all
this press and everyone started talking
about the book and
all this stuff and all the craziness
with the left and the difference between
liberals and leftism
it was all stuff that i had been
thinking about for years i had been
writing about and then suddenly it was
like
super relevant and then also because i
called it don't burn this book and then
they were burning down the stores that
the book was in and everything else
but what i realized was if i'm going to
write a book and tell people what i
think and then
if i'm going to do this show which you
know this direct message
i've only been doing since september it
was like well now i'm not just an
interviewer i
i am someone that tells people what i
think for a living for better or worse
right for right or wrong so i better
tell them absolutely everything i think
and and not be afraid to do it
but i will tell you it has come with a
cost over the last you know four or five
months as i've been more outspoken about
my beliefs
you know still i i'm getting i'm getting
hit
from friends or former friends and and
some family members and
you know telling people what you think
in a time when
uh people are afraid to say what they
think can kind of be dangerous but what
i've realized is
every time i've done that i've not held
back and i've said what i
thought whether it ultimately was right
or wrong
i've felt better through it and i think
that that's what will happen to you too
if you're if you're holding in whatever
it is
if you're afraid to tell people what you
think the more you let
it out just say it if your friends drop
you they're not your real friends and i
think what you'll always find and i
assure you i have found it is you will
find new and better friends
but it's not just about where you can
find friends it's also
you gotta you are what you are i am what
i am and that's all that i am i'm popeye
the sailor man you know what i'm saying
that's it
that's it that's all you can do and one
thing that really has helped me truly is
that
my two best friends in life my buddies
john and arie
john i met first day of kindergarten we
were like four years old and harry moved
to town when we were in third grade
and we're still as good friends now
almost 40 years later
and that kind of thing has helped me
grounded you know i think it's important
to have
long-term friends and not just
fair-weather friends
nikki says is joe manchin a democrat to
be somewhat trusted like tulsi
yeah somewhat but i think when you're
sort of in that waffling
center place especially on the democrat
side the energy
of the radicals will will always drag
you that way so the idea
i see this a lot that republicans are
kind of like well i guess we sort of
have joe manchin or he's not completely
bananas
i don't know i don't think that that
really can hold you don't know what
pressures he can
withstand or or what they could do look
you guys know my feelings about tulsi
and she's become a good friend of mine
and she just launched on locals and i
think she has a bright
future ahead of her whether it's
political or pundit or having nothing to
do with any of this if she just wants to
surf
for the rest of her life which i think
would probably make her the most happy
um but but a voice like hers who was
going to go against the squad who was
calm and decent and about healing not
not forcing you to heal but true healing
of a nation
they they went they said she's awful
hillary clinton basically said she was a
russian spy
and then the party just basically kicked
her out so that that is the party right
now
what do you want me to do what can we do
i don't know uh
moon tide says do you think that the
vast divide between liberals and
conservatives is permanent
and will americans ever come together
again or always view each other through
an us
verse them lens look i i've tried for
years to bridge this thing i think in
many ways
in many ways in the public uh sphere
like i was the guy bridging it right
because i was saying hey i was a lefty
i'm really fighting for liberalism
that's not very different from
libertarianism and let's talk to
conservatives go back
to my videos when i'm first talking to
shapiro
and prager and back in all of these guys
and you can see
we're trying to go hey we want to live
in the same world that was what the idw
was all about when that thing was
burning hot and now it's falling apart
for many reasons and i've
lost a lot of respect for a lot of
people for a series of other reasons
um but like we were talking about all
sorts of things the example i always use
was sam harris and ben shapiro disagree
on literally everything the nature
of reality and existence and god and
every existential issue but they also
disagree on taxes and they disagree on
abortion and they disagree on
virtually every political issue and yet
we were all able to sit around and talk
about these things
and then maybe the pressures became too
much that it did
sort of crumble i don't know how you
bridge that divide anymore
at least right now i think at a micro
level you can bridge that divide and
i will always try to do look i'll always
try to do it on a macro level on this
show and welcome people who i disagree
with okay so let me just put that out
there for sure
on a micro level i think you have a much
better chance of doing it whether that
means talking to your friends and family
or being involved in your local
communities um
but the the national like the show must
just
the show must go on version of politics
it ain't gonna get better and that's why
this this fake idea
of healing right now they don't mean
healing they mean we've got a lot of
power and if you shut up we'll heal
that's not healing in a free society
free societies everyone can get in and
say what they think and fight for what
they believe in as long as they do it
peacefully
and i fear that now that the democrats
have the presidency
and you know have the senate because of
the tiebreaker and have big
tech it's like it's going to get smaller
and smaller as far as what you're
allowed to talk about and aoc is telling
it right
she that's what she's telling us i did a
couple shows yesterday where we talked
about this she's putting up there
you know these truth and reconciliation
commissions and we shouldn't be allowed
to spread misinformation and we might
have to have media literacy training
she doesn't mean media literacy training
like like let's learn
all sorts of different things let's
let's learn about the ideas of
capitalism and freedom and liberty
she means media literacy like oh those
are the bad evil ideas
america is evil and we can we the new
socialists are the ones who can usher it
in
i mean that's just the truth when bernie
says i want free college for everyone do
you think he means
because he wants everyone to truly be
educated in the sense that
you will learn a wide swath of ideas and
and the best ones will win out or
would you really want everyone to go to
college for free which isn't free
so that you can brainwash the most
amount of people which do you think
bernie really wants do you think bernie
wants people
to go to college to learn from people
like thomas soule i don't think so
stefan asks do you think we've entered
the mob rule phase
i do think we're in it for a little bit
right now
we are at least again at the macro level
the way the whole
system is going to work the way
mainstream media and big tech and
everything else
is going to work yes mob rule it is
going to get harder and harder
to say whatever you believe and fight
for what you believe in publicly
and all that without feeling like you're
going to get banned or shadow banned and
everything else again this is the stuff
that i was warning about for a long time
but i do
think we are there but i will say this
there is a silver lining coming
guys this is going to be what i want to
use as the promo today because i've been
thinking about it all morning
there is a silver lining coming and the
silver lining is this
as this hysterical authoritarian
monster grows as big government now
coupled with big
tech grows it will import all the bad
ideas all the bad ideas of critical race
theory all the bad ideas of social
justice and identity politics
it will bring them all in it will hire
people in governmental positions
and in tech positions and in business
positions and on boards of major
companies
that are not based on the content of
their character or their skill or their
hard work or their education
but on the color of their skin or some
other immutable characteristic
and over time companies and governments
that do that
don't hire the best people because
they're the best people but hire the
people
that are this or that because they look
like this or that
the systems that they create that they
create will fail those systems will fail
i promise you that
and what what we free loving people
liberty loving people have to do right
now is start
creating things i saw this coming and
that's why i started locals.com over two
years ago and we are working on every
technological
solution to all of this stuff but it's
not just that
it's that government now will bring in
people
who will bring in so many bad ideas that
they will fail
things have gone from they're not too
big to fail they're too big to succeed
and i think we're going to see that at
the governmental level and i think we're
going to see it
at the big tech level so build things
for yourself
it doesn't just mean tech whatever
whatever that means to you build a
stronger family build a stronger
local school local community whatever
that is
do it and then we will have a chance
again i promise you we will
ginger says dave i'd love to know about
the current subscriber and creator base
here at locals.com how many community
members site-wide how
many creators and given the crazy growth
of late any projections for the
remainder of the year
there is a ton going on with locals i
want to assure you that we
we have backup servers that we're
working on payment processor issues
and again we have an extremely strong
terms of service that has been evolving
especially over the last couple days
you cannot threaten violence on locals
and by the way it's never happened once
on locals i go on twitter i've got
people you know everyone's calling
everyone else a nazi but you've got
white supremacists on there you've got
crazy antifa people on there
nobody does anything about it let's just
put that aside
we've built a really elegant system with
a little bit of a paywall so starting
this week
we were allowing free locals communities
now every local community is paid so if
you're creating a local community and
anyone can do it you don't have to be a
creator in a traditional sense if you
have
a restaurant and you want to create your
own community if you have a baseball
league and you want to create your own
community if you're an unboxer or a
gamer or a political guy or
whatever you might be uh the minimum
that we ask people to subscribe for is
two dollars just a little
something to get in by the way locals
the company only takes 10
of that that's the same amount as
patreon but that way it encourages good
behavior
uh we're also selling coins on locals
now we're working on
getting them on the blockchain like
there's a lot of cool stuff that we're
doing
um i don't know that i can give you i
don't know that my team would love if i
gave all of the numbers i can
show you that the numbers are absolutely
exploding but i can tell you that right
now we have almost a hundred thousand
um members in the reuben report locals
and just about ten thousand of them are
paying members that means that that are
active community members who engage in
all the content
and support what we do here and keep me
free and and get videos early and ad
free
and all of that stuff and and also know
that if i was to be booted off
everything tomorrow i could still
communicate with everybody so we're
growing tremendously fast
and and check it out just go to
reubenreport.locals.com check out the
community
and just look at the level of content
there and look at the level of
communication there and
i think you'll see it has a little bit
more of an inkling of what social media
was supposed to be like this
rather than the hellscape that is the
twitter machine
um alex says did you expect the
censorship and de-platforming
to happen this quickly we're already
seeing no-fly lists banking and lending
institutions
withholding services tech companies
banding together to throw their
competition off the internet it's only a
matter of time before they come after
normal people too how soon do you think
that will happen and what can we do
about it yeah
it's the coordination right now that i
think is really scaring people suddenly
it's like wait a minute now we've got
people on no-fly lists which i talked
about the no-fly list yesterday the
no-fly list makes no sense to me
it doesn't make sense to me uh whether
it's related to terror
or whether it's related to whatever
happened on the capitol or anything else
like it's like wait a minute we know
that these are
in their eyes these are sort of bad
people they can do whatever they want
society they just can't get on a plane
like is there any evidence to think that
anyone that rioted at the capitol or
just walked into the capitol building
and by the way they should be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
for breaking the law uh is there any
evidence to think that these people are
going to suddenly be hijacking planes
like you're going to let them get in the
car and drive cross-country but they
can't fly there so we're just going to
extend their trip that
that'll be the real inconvenience for
these people it's going to take you four
days to get to
from california to new york as opposed
to six hours and uh you know well they
don't i was about to say and you're not
going to get any of that fancy plane
food but they don't serve that anymore
either
um yes the worrying collusion between
these companies that they can
all decide at one moment to take you out
that then this could move down to the
banking layer
and if they found out you're a trump
supporter should you be allowed to bank
and should at t be allowed to stop you
from getting a phone
and the rest of it and that's why this
has been so complex this issue about big
tech
because think about it 50 years ago when
when phone lines
it's i mean even more than that but 50
years ago phone everyone has a phone in
their house well
should the government have been able the
government or the companies that were
putting the phone lines in
been able to have listened to your
conversations
and then based on those conversations
decided whether you should have a phone
or not
that's why this is all so dangerous but
again i truly truly believe that human
ingenuity is the answer
there will be decentralized blockchain
based answers to all of these things
it's going to take time and can they
destroy a lot of people's lives in the
meantime they absolutely can
they absolutely can but my new year's
resolution was to be a little bit braver
and i just think if you're a little bit
braver
in the midst of this that it will work
out for you who is that old guy that
there was this liberal guy a long time
ago what did he say
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
remember that guy he used to be a good
liberal now he'd be a right-wing maniac
that was jfk by the way
um there's nothing to fear but fear
itself it's like we can get through this
i just know we can get through it
and by the way as i've said a couple
times over the last few days one of the
things we're trying to do with locals is
i am not trying to replace all of these
things i think they will fail on their
own we're going to build you a digital
home so that you can exist on the
internet and set some rules
for yourself and your community and and
i want to work i genuinely want to if
you're watching this
amazon representative facebook
representative google representative
whatever it might be
i want to work with you guys i'm not
here to burn down the system but the
more you won't work with people
the more that people are going to want
to work down the system burn down the
system
i put up a tweet the other day that got
something like 10 000 retweets saying
i'm willing to interview any
representative from any of these
companies i'll do it without notes i'll
do it live
just give me somebody to talk to about
the philosophical issues here the legal
issues
the constraints the technological issues
um it seems like you cannot get a
representative from any of these
companies to talk to anybody so it's
like
we voluntarily get on these platforms
then they set arbitrary rules and then
won't even talk to us about it you think
that's a problem
i'm starting to think it's a problem
ramona says it sounds to me as though
the left is just making themselves a
self-created judicial tribunal
that was written about in the lynch law
in 1780 it's as though we are going to
be presumed guilty without legal
representation this has to stop
but how you know you remember the third
uh
batman movie the third in the trilogy
with bain which one what was that called
dark knight returns is that is that what
it was was that dark knight returned
that one uh the main one the third one
yeah i think it was dark night returns
dark
uh dark knight rises is that what it was
dark knight rises yeah um
if you remember in that one uh when they
were all locked you know they basically
uh cut off gotham from the rest of the
world right they blow up the bridges
and then they start having these
tribunals and the guy who is the
scarecrow in the first of the movies
is running these clown courts and
they're executing people in the
in the icy river and everything it's
like it sort of feels like we're getting
there that we're not gonna have real
legal system
uh that is functional or the presumption
of innocence or due process or any of
those things
these guys don't really like those
things they like power
so again scary this this is
scary so how does it as you you the
question here is this has to stop but
how it has to stop yes
and how we must just continue to stand
up against it that that is the only
thing we can do right now
dixie says do you think we're in a
digital civil war we are
we are there is a big machine and there
are people who desire to be free
i don't think those things have to be in
an intractable war forever i believe
those things can
there are issues you don't want people
making violent threats you don't want
people
or coordinating terrorism or some of the
really bad things that can be out there
how do you balance that with free speech
and everything else it's like that's
what we should be talking about right
now what
is more important than that right now is
that what congress should be talking
about or should we talk about a
president
who's going to be impeached or going to
walk out in six days should we be
wasting time impeaching him that's what
we should be talking about that's the
future
of freedom if you care about freedom
but as i said the companies won't even
talk about it and our politicians are
idiots
neil says do you think there is any
treatment of trump supporters that
democrats would publicly disavow i think
they've been gaslit into generally
being all right with concentration camps
or worse at this point i mean
putting the concentration camp part
aside it's like no i think
i think in a weird way this is what they
wanted was the capitol hill event
they wanted that to happen because then
they could shift it all from going oh
they're nazis and white supremacists in
this vague sense whatever that means to
you
to now they're terrorists and even
though
antifa people don't represent all
democrats or all liberals or black lives
matter people don't represent all
democrats or liberals or lefties this
obviously represents everyone on the
right and that's just
crazy that's absolutely just crazy i
have no doubt that 95
of the people that were there who were
singing the national anthem and waving
american flags they were just there
to to do their god-given right of
protest which we have enshrined in the
constitution here at least for now
so we're again we're in a i can't
sugarcoat it and that we're not in a
weird spot right now but i do think
there is uh
a silver lining along the way which is
that we must fight for freedom more and
a lot of people are waking up to it
craig
he's changing it up for me did you end
up liking the mandalorian season two
thought it would be a great uh uh maybe
a non-political question
would be cool yes i loved it the final
two episodes
finally brought it around i've said all
along i need a little jedi in my star
wars you can't
do star wars without the jedi i need to
see a lightsaber every now and again
it was very very cool having luke come
back defeat the dark jedi
save grogu sorry for the spoilers but
this is weeks already so i think i i
think
that thing has sailed um you know and
everything my feelings
about mark hamill aside because he's
become like sort of the worst kind of
like progressive lefty nut bag and
they've ruined star wars in many ways
but it was actually very cool
to see and i and i'm psyched about uh
the book of boba fett which will be the
spin-off of this thing
um but in many ways it sort of felt to
me that they could have ended
mandalorian right there it's like
grogu baby yoda got rescued and it's
like now the mandalorian's job of these
last two seasons was over
and that's that um rose says do you
think locals or any other alternative
media such as the daily wire will ever
be shut down and if the day comes when
the left wakes up to what's happening
do you think there's a chance that if we
band together we can rise up against the
system big government
big tech etc etc look they could shut
down everybody at any moment
tim poole just texted me a minute before
i went live saying that facebook
just suspended his account so i don't
know if that's up yet or not or what's
going on there
um could they do it to anybody
yes there are i mean anyone that's
telling you right now that there are
perfect technological solutions to this
is lying it's just not true there are
not perfect storage
answers there are not perfect payment
answers yet like it all hasn't been
pieced together we are working seriously
hard
at locals we've got we've got some of
the best tech people
on it and we are having the
philosophical issues and finding all the
choke points and doing
all of the work to do all of that stuff
as i said we've got redundancies if
amazon just took us out tomorrow but
again
i want to work with these companies we
have a much tighter
and more honest terms of service than
the big tech companies do and because of
the paywall we have no bad behavior but
the point is
and i think this is your broader point
is that even if you do
everything perfectly by the rules that
they set up they could still take you
out so we we've got a lot of work to do
but i have nothing better to do peter
says what kind of beers
and wine do you like most of you guys
know i'm a wine guy
i'll give you a great wine there's not a
sponsor or anything else
a great wine you can get for about 16
bucks it's a cab
from sonoma called uppercut i think it
is
like you could drink a 50 bottle or a 75
bottle and it tastes like one of those i
just think it's great and that's what
i'm that's what i'm usually drinking i'm
not a huge beer guy but i do like a
a good ipa every now and again and if
you really want to treat yourself to
like a really spectacular
bottle of wine it's about 100 bucks i've
only bought maybe
three of them in my whole life for
special occasions there's a bottle
called deranged by prisoner winery that
that's pretty awesome and shout out to
chris
my youtube manager who's watching this
right now i have no doubt
and he got me one for the holidays thank
you chris we haven't drank it yet but we
will soon
lauren says thoughts on andrew yang
running for mayor of new york city
love the interview with him look i think
he's a decent guy i don't believe in ubi
he he's more of a big government guy
than i am i didn't love the fact that he
went down to georgia to campaign it's
like
it sort of feels like just like this
carpet bagging thing like you just moved
to places to get involved in politics
he did live in new york city for some
portion of his life i'd like to play
basketball with the guy
again i think he's decent and at least
he's thinking about things a little bit
differently
but you know in effect he pulled at zero
i saw a lot of the
you know the good liberals were just
saying they were part of the yang gang
because i think it was their way of
saying the democrats are bananas but i
can't vote for trump or i don't want to
publicly be seen voting for trump
but i don't think government is the
answer to this
and that's the irony of someone like
yang and i would love to talk andrew if
your people are watching this and i know
some of them are fans
or if you're watching this i'd love to
discuss this with you that i do think
the answer comes through technology
and decentralization and everything else
i don't think the answer comes through
government
so i'm always leery at this point of
anyone that wants to get into the
government
but he sees an opportunity to get back
in the game there and he's going for it
uh joe says what do you think the odds
are that the u.s
breaks up do you think that the states
will secede and form their own countries
man i mean look this
it's crazy that we're even talking about
this
but if we are in a truly intractable
place that that states that want to be
open and free and and take a little bit
of risk
if those if those states florida texas
for example
don't want to be part of the machine
anymore that seems to be getting
bigger and bigger and federal laws for
everything
uh if they don't want to be part of this
thing and then they don't want to help
bail out
the states that are failing right like
so i get it man if you're somebody in
texas who's living by the rules and
you're in a nose
uh income tax state and your state is
open and good and you don't want all the
blue state people moving there and
ruining everything and then when
california falters financially you don't
want to pay for it like i could
i can see why you'd be kind of resentful
i hope it doesn't happen and abraham
lincoln you know everyone says abraham
lincoln who
you say who's the who's the best
president of the united states almost
everyone says abraham lincoln why was he
the best president of the united states
because he saved the union we may be
getting to a point where this thing is
so huge that that maybe it can't be
saved
and i don't like talking about it or
thinking about it but i i do think
that states will have to start making
some more decisions for themselves
and ron desantis the governor of florida
is the guy that's just absolutely
knocking it out of the park all right
just a couple more i know i'm over time
here
but i know that there's a lot here uh
tim says uh how does one see any
available jobs
at locals we're hiring like across the
board we need more developers we need
more architecture people we need more
onboarding people and customer success
and everything else
jobs at locals.com there isn't a public
we haven't had time even because there's
so much going on uh to put up a public
uh posting just email your resume with a
nice cover letter
tell them you're a fan of dave rubin
tell them dave sent you
jobs locals.com isaiah says as someone
who
also loves to cook do you have any
recommendations on excellent wine
whiskey and meal pairings
i mean you guys see my my go-to is well
i just mentioned uppercut
uh cab and then you give me a freaking
beautiful oh i cooked such a beautiful
one from snake river farms i got a uh
it was a tomahawk a four pound tomahawk
i posted some pictures in the community
i think it was the best steak i've ever
made
i sear it super hot two sides just salt
and pepper i might have done
did i do like a little bit of garlic
powder sometimes or like a traeger rub
that that sasha on one is pretty solid
but just salt and pepper is good enough
and you can't do too much salt on a big
steak that's the trick
sear it four minutes on each side then
maybe kind of slow cook it for about a
half hour i mean this was a seriously
thick steak
um with it with a nice cab there's
nothing better uh dan says super
important question do you think that han
solo shot first yes he shot first it
never should have been edited
and han was a badass that was what was
cool about him han had to do
some [ __ ] to make a living in the galaxy
okay the idea that he wouldn't have shot
credo first
because he's just a nice guy that's not
that's against the ethos of the
character
he was about to be taken out by greedo
greedo was about to bring him to jabba
okay greeto's not a great guy jabba's
not a good guy it's like you're going to
shoot him all right two more
nate have you made a prediction for 2021
yet if so i haven't heard it i'm pretty
sure there's a way to look at the year
ahead
that's not all doom and gloom there's
got to be positivity in there somewhere
you know usually the last like five
years i've done a massive twitter thread
um with my predictions and they've been
actually pretty on point
but i didn't do it this year because it
was just it's been a little chaotic and
i just didn't do it
but the silver lining again guys is
the silver lining is we have they can't
take us
all out they can't take us all out i
know it feels like they can
but if we keep doing things meaning
whatever it is you want to do as things
start opening
if if you're looking at your life going
boy that was a weird year and i really
wasn't doing the stuff that i wanted to
do i didn't work at a job
i really wanted to work at i didn't live
with the person i really wanted to live
at or i was addicted to this or i was
doing that or
whatever it is you can always turn it
around and i think
while this will be a year of sort of
authoritarian hysterical
craziness they can't get everybody so so
fix some stuff for yourself that's what
i'm trying to do that's what i'm trying
to do
and melanie finally what's your favorite
seinfeld episode all i'm doing right now
by the way is watching seinfeld that i'm
not watching anything else
i've just had it with all of these shows
um i'm watching seinfeld
um what's my favorite episode you know
someone asked me this the other day
one of my favorite episodes is season
two or three it's that that
subway episode where they all go on
their own adventures on the subway
and that that scene with elaine in the
subway car when the lights are going off
and she thinks people are touching and
you're just listening to what she's
thinking in her mind it's such like a
perfect
quintessential new york city moment
because we've all had that
but pound for pound my favorite
episode
you know it's got to be something it's
got to be something with jerry's parents
the whole dell boca vista situation
jerry's dad getting impeached because he
has a cadillac so they think he's
embezzling funds like it's a pretty
perfect episode so
uh there you go uh okay guys uh i am
giving my team off tomorrow because we
decided we're not gonna have people
working on monday for mlk day
and everything has been so crazy that
i'm actually giving everybody offer
tomorrow so we can have a four day
weekend uh so congratulations to my team
not that there's anyone else in this
room sorry gavin newsom
um so there'll be no direct message
tomorrow or
monday i will see you tuesday we will be
live am i right
we are live with special guest ron paul
i have wanted ron paul on forever
he was the leader of the of the tea
party movement and he has been a fighter
for liberty
we've wanted to do this interview for
years we were hoping to do it live he
doesn't fly a lot because you're not
going to believe this he doesn't like
the tsa
but finally last week his channel was
temporarily banned from facebook
we reached out to his people about
locals hopefully there'll be something
on that soon too
and we were able to do this we're going
to do it via skype i'm thrilled to do it
and if you haven't seen it yet just this
morning we posted part one of my
interview
with journalist note i didn't have to do
this an actual journalist
by the name of john bachman from newsmax
i go on his show all the time he's an
actual journalist trying to give
information to people it's
very very bizarre and uh oh
i'm on his show in what like an hour or
something i'm on his show today i think
at uh 11 o'clock pacific or something
like that around there ball parking it
okay uh so that's it have a great
extended weekend everybody stay calm
stay cool stay collected it's all going
to be okay
and i won't be on all the major social
media platforms obviously
over the next couple days as well but i
will be saying hi to everybody and maybe
doing some live chats and videos and
food pictures and dog pictures and all
that at reubenreport.locals.com
see you tuesday